he does stand-up 3 to dabble
he doesn't yeah you need to go full
force or I'm a sketch boy every stand-up
is like oh you're a sketchy boy I'm like
yeah why do you say sketch boy give me a
suggestion and you got like tiny
underwear I love sketch sketch is the
hardest form I feel like it's like
impossible everything is funny
yeah nothing is [ __ ] funny and
sketchy it's so rare like that yeah but
I feel like everyone is the audience is
so much more forgiving they laugh at
every time they had to put a wig on I'll
give ya would say every UCB show I've
gone like people are just so supportive
there's a stand-up you know I've gone
religious crickets well cuz people go I
can do better than that
yeah always everybody thinks they can do
stand-up everybody I know I swear it's a
phenomenon it is but they don't do it no
not everybody can do stand-up that's
fine and they try it I love it I love
when people dudes mm-hmm that go yeah I
can do it yeah I mean no problem and
then they do it
and they eat a miserable death yeah and
I like watching it feels you
it doesn't feel me it just makes me go
you know just smile like this is not
this is very difficult
mm-hmm you know I always see those just
I I feel like some of them would just be
lifers like some um he persuaded me one
year and thought it'd be a good idea for
me to go to open mikes yeah
so I begrudgingly did but he only did it
just so I could feel the agony and
misery and torture yeah he had no other
motive other than to just make me
miserable yeah
so I was miserable I went to a handful
of them but I found that there are
lifers that are life let our open mike
rizzo probably been doing it for 20
years
oh my god yes that's why they never saw
and they never but never interesting is
it an outlet or they just don't have
they're delusional like I can't I think
it's a mixture I have the problem
there's some delusions in comedy where I
in relationships where are and this is a
character defect of mine and other
comics know that I used to
yeah but you know I used to like with my
relationships kind of I'd like I did two
kalila yeah like with Christine she is
she's an accountant yes right and she's
like I convinced her that she could be
an actress getting headshots I got an
agent right and then I remember going to
an audition with her a commercial
audition sitting there and I had a
revelation why do you why do you make
him do it I don't know why it's a I
could have a child I call this [ __ ]
almost immediately though yeah I mean
there's it's a power thing for him yeah
he was he's a [ __ ] puppeteer he wants
to know that he can just put you in his
palms and then wave you around to an
audience you know and that's the mean
because I'm sure she really believed
that because she cared about your your
opinion and he does this a lot to a lot
of open mic or just keep doing it you're
really talented like no he [ __ ] ate
it what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and he tells him quit your job move to
LA and you know it and he told he told
one of his good friends
um who's not doing very well in another
feel he said do just just do stand-up
man you're gonna be really great Bobby
I'm a surgeon I'm a neurosurgeon right
Bob why don't ya why do I do that
because you want to see MIT scale so you
all submit pad you know it has your ego
to it apparently I have control I have
control problems too like Nick like
whenever Nick does stuff with us just as
friends Mike what about me
like I want to be like involved in what
about I have like that yeah that's not
your thing yeah cuz I walk cuz I didn't
speak English night it was like what are
you talking about
[Music]